Here we go in five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes,
at all.
The fucking people that make me feel lazy in this world is to make me feel you
in the rock.
You fuckers don't look like.
Do you ever sleep?
Not Enough.
No days off.
That's what I love is unattractive as he's,
uh,
he's a,
he's a person that,
that motivates me,
inspires me in the fact that where we're coworkers,
we're friends.
Um,
I think it's a,
I think it's like a,
it's a blessing.
It's a blessing to be around that because it truly,
it's,
it's uplifting.
You know,
it makes you,
it just makes you weed out to circle.
When you're around people that truly give you,
like,
uh,
give you some good,
serve a good value to you and your life,
you then look at those that don't,
and you can,
you can then push away.
So I'm big on,
I'm big on personality.
I'm big on energy.
I'm big on will.
And once,
uh,
I believe that is contagious.
So if you have a,
a bunch of laziness and a bunch of bullshit around you,
naturally it's going to feed off.
You're going to find yourself becoming what's in your environment.
So I feel the exact same way.
And when I see it though,
can I see that in you?
I see that in,
you know,
so I feel like it's a scene that Avatar I see you.
I see you.
Yeah,
but a guy like that,
I was like,
I always wonder like how much of that is like I've had sleep experts on the
podcast and tell you like,
like this real problems.
If you don't get enough sleep like you could,
you have a much higher risk of Alzheimer's.
All those other serious issues.
But I see a guy like the rock,
I'm like,
how the fuck does he sleep?
Well,
where's the room to fall asleep?
You know that,
that's true.
I can't say that,
um,
that I've witnessed the sleep patterns,
but he's a,
he's a late ass,
so he does,
I know he's sleeping is something,
where are we waiting on DJ?
God Damn it.
He's probably getting his rest,
which is well deserved.
Um,
but you know when you,
when you say you had these sleep experts and stuff on,
it's always a thing that I go back and forth about it because what is enough
sleep like I'm a person.
I function high off of six to seven hours.
Yeah.
Six seven hours.
I'm,
I'm functioning.
Yeah,
five hours.
I'm great.
Do I do the five hour thing all the time?
No,
but if I have to I'm fine.
Um,
I don't need the eight and a nine.
I thought like that's too much for me.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I'm an early riser and now that I'm getting older,
you know,
if I can get in that bed by nine 30 or 10 on a off work day,
I'm very happy with that.
But then I'm up at five 30 I'm up at five.
So what is enough sleep?
What did they tell you is enough?
It really depends on the person.
There are people that have a gene where they can just sleep four hours a night.
I got fine.
You might got it.
I got that.
Is that a,
does it,
what does that,
what does that mean?
Motherhood is gold.
What does that,
what does it means?
You've got special jeans day.
Write a mail.
He got some shit.
There are,
there are people that just don't need as much.
They can,
they can go a long time without sleep.
Diagnosed me,
I'm one of those people he brought in.
You might be,
I bet a lot of high functioning people are because your body tends to get more
efficient.
You know,
like you're,
you're always going,
you're always burning yard.
So your body's like,
when it's time to shut down,
it's like shut down.
Get that five,
six hours in.
All right.
I will,
I will confess this.
I am an amazing Catnapper.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm one of those guys.
If you stop talking to me long enough,
I'm a fault slip right here.
I something about silence real and just not doing anything and I just,
well,
it's probably,
you're probably going on momentum all the time.
You probably,
you're probably going on motivation and momentum.
Then when your body has his break,
he probably was like,
we could use a little sleep right here at 100% right.
I'm dead serious.
That's,
I know for sure that that's accurate because I'm,
how can happen heartbeat.
Do you feel like you've hit a good balance?
So this is what I was wondering about with guys like you are guys like the rock.
When I look at your Instagram,
your social media,
and you're just constantly going like,
God damn.
Do you ever feel like you do too much?
Like maybe I just need to take a little break here.
Do you ever feel like that?
I think the perception definitely perceives reality.
You know,
uh,
what it looks like so much isn't always so much because you have a schedule and
you know,
within that schedule there's the things that mean the most that come and act as
downtime.
You know,
me and my house is downtime even though it's still active and I've got to be dad
and I'm with the kids and a wife in this conversation and I'm running around in
the back and forth.
That's still acts as downtime for me.
Like I'm shutting a work off.
So the phone is any office,
I'm not going back to get it until the morning.
And it's all conversation.
It's all TV,
it's all Taco Tuesdays.
It's couching Cuddlin uh,
you know,
baby time,
whatever.
That's my downtime because,
um,
I've taken a step outside of the other shit that's was,
that's,
that's what I think I do very well.
I can step outside the other shit.
I can separate it.
So I think when you're able to do that,
then you're,
you're managing your mental,
you know what I mean?
Like if it's,
if it's always one thing all the time,
that's how you fucking drive yourself crazy because you'd never,
you'd never shutting it off.
Yeah.
And I think I do a good job of shutting,
shutting this off in focusing on this.
Like when I'm with my family,
I want my family.
Nothing is,
nothing interjects or comes in between.
That's fantastic.
That's so important.
It's 100%.
That's beautiful.
That's gigantic.
I think I figured it out.
That's it,
man.
I think I figured it out.
You mean you've got so much success?
It's not like you have to be with that fucking phone all the time.
It's that the phone is the big one
right on the phone.
The phone is,
is the gift and a curse.
You know,
I think that we,
we shot out the gate and saw the Gif.
Oh my God.
It's,
it's,
it's community is connecting us.
We're able to share,
we're able to meet new people where we're able to stay in communication with,
with old people,
find new people as entertainer.
I can engage with my fans and this is so dope.
And then after that,
you get hit with the,
the curse.
And the curse is,
there's a,
there's a high level of negativity that's out there that's on that shit.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of people that are,
you know,
not happy or,
or going through things and they interject,
uh,
a certain amount of negativity and hatred through these devices.
These devices are the easiest way to touch everybody.
So when you're just consumed on that shit all day,
you start to see yourself being a part of the negative shit.
So what I've learned to do is go,
I don't,
I don't need to see that.
I don't need to see that shit.
I don't,
I don't pay that any mind.
I don't read that Shit for what?
It's not,
it's not helping me.
It's not making me better.
It's not,
it's not a pushing me to new limits.
If anything is taken up,
just creative space by me literally spending time going and,
and,
and navigating through what I think is,
is a bunch of bullshit so I don't let the device beat me.
And at one point I definitely did.
At one point it was everything.
It was everything.
It was,
you know,
now separated.
I'm not clear of it would work when you realize what it is,
when you see,
when you see the bed,
you know when you see the bad side of it.
I thought the other day this is some real shit and it really made me think my
phone died,
my phone died and I'm driving and I was using the fucking maps and I was like,
Oh shit,
what the fuck?
How am I get to where I don't know where I'm going.
And I sat and I was like,
Yo,
how did we,
how did we get from point a to point B before the map shit.
What are we doing that I used to print out directions from Google maps.
I remember that,
but then before that,
how did you get to the places where you were going that you didn't know how to
get to?
I don't even remember.
Do you remember Thomas Guides?
Do you ever have a Thomas Guide?
I did have a Thomas Guide.
When I first moved to la I would get one of them.
I did have a Thomas Guide giant ask a hundred percent bill burr had
bill probably still uses it.
Shouts out to bill burr,
but it really fucked me up because I was like,
how do we don't even know how,
how to do the common,
the the the norm anymore because the device has made everything available and I
literally had to to drive to a store rack it,
buy a charger to charge up my phone to get back and use the mat to get to where
the fuck I was going.
I said I had no idea how to get there.
I had no,
I didn't know know numbers by heart.
I didn't know who I was going to call like,
Yo,
this is the moment where I was like,
what level of success have I reached?
I just pulled over and I sat there and I was like,
how the fuck am I going to get the round goes spare phone man.
I don't know what it would backup phone.
It felt like the end of the world.
It felt,
it felt like it was over.
I was like shit and the crazy head of pen that you are,
but that's when the light bulb started to click started.
They click like how?
How do we function with out?
I want to go backwards a little bit.
It's still there.
I still need it.
I still think it's dope with all of the things that we can do on it,
but I still want to be able to put it down and step away from it and then my
kids to be able to step away from it.
That's why when I come in the house,
my phone was up cause I can't,
I can't bitch.
You could plan at y'all about being on your phone if you see me doing the same
thing.
Right.
So that time,
those conversations,
me wanting to know about your day,
you talking to me about your day,
your friends,
who you like,
who don't you like my daughter.
You what boy?
Who?
What?
Ha No,
I got my son.
Yeah,
I like somebody who,
oh,
Jesus.
Here coms.
It's,
yes,
it's a great thing and I want to be able to have those moments and you know,
I think it's,
it's,
it's big to make sure that you prioritize that.
Are you worried about what comes next?
100%.
I'm worried that something's going to be way more intrusive than that.
It's,
it's,
what do you mean it's already happening?
The biggest scare happened already with the,
the,
the facetime shit that happened where?
Well Apple,
uh,
on the iPhone it was like people could listen in to your,
oh yeah,
if you didn't need to pick up.
Yeah.
They could just listen into it and you know,
that was the scariest shit ever because it's,
if it's that easy to have a bug like that,
what's the thing that's not a bug that's there that you just don't know about?
Oh there's definitely government listened to us 100% 100% everything everybody
says and then in case one day you do something wrong,
they go back to,
sorry Mr. Hart was like,
you sit down for a minute,
why am I you something hundred percent so the fear is the next level of
immersion intrusive.
You know,
I think everything is become intrusive now.
Like the toughest thing for me is that there is no,
there is no privacy outside my home.
You know,
the,
the amount of money that you have to now spin just on security,
on,
you know,
people to be with me,
security to be on my home.
You know,
it's like there literally is no privacy and it's not a bitch and complain about
it because without the fans,
without the people that support me,
I wouldn't be where I am.
But there is no middle ground.
You know,
there is no handshakes anymore.
It's,
it's how you doing.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
The handshake is so much better to get a moment like we didn't talk if that's
what you were not an all y'all was saying now it's kind of weird cause you doing
this to me,
it's kind of weird to have a conversation.
So you're just starting to see yourself become a little older and wiser and uh,
just really see the times for what they are and see the direction that we're
going in this people and just hope and pray that we find a middle ground.
Because I think right now there isn't one.
Yeah,
that's what I'm feeling now.
No,
I feel it too.
And especially,
I mean,
what you're talking about is you being super famous and losing all your privacy,
but everyone's losing their privacy and slowly but surely it's,
it's happening to you because you're very famous and because you do something
that's in the public eye and people want to see you and they want to stick the
camera in front of you.
But there's gonna come a point in time where what we're dealing with now,
which is like you have to turn your phone on,
you have to,
you know,
yeah.
I have to reach out to somebody.
You have to put something up that's,
that step's going to be out of the way and it's just going to be people being
able to access your life.
Yeah.
Pretty,
you know,
to bad,
here's what I'll say is bad.
That really fucks with me.
I don't like that negativity is the,
the want,
you know,
like,
like the,
the thing that's popular is the failure the fuck up.
You know,
the,
the fight that I can catch,
the hateful moment that I can catch and posts like the bad is being highlighted
and celebrated.
That's what fucks with me.
What the social media shit.
Now,
what,
what really bothers me is,
you know,
when you see these things online,
like,
you know,
uh,
a fight and there's a man hitting a woman and is captured.
Right.
That's bad.
The bad thing is that you watched that the video was more important than the
actual help.
Right.
Or the moment to step in.
And you know,
when you see these things where you're catching people do these things to kids
in this caught the moment of what you got in,
what you want to post and get likes or whatever on is the focus instead of the
help and that,
and that's,
that's the part that is just,
I just have a hard time processing.
I have a hard time processing what the likes mean to certain people.
Well,
you get an extraordinary amount of attention so it doesn't mean anything to you.
It means something to a regular person.
Went to a regular person,
they can catch some worldstar video and put it up there.
Like,
dude,
that's my video.
That's my video hooked my video,
got 5 million hits,
my video has gone viral,
my videos everywhere.
For them it's like,
it's a point of excitement.
That's why when they see you,
they're like,
oh shit.
How often are they going to run into Kevin Hart
at Costco or wherever the fuck you were?
Why did to me on a,
you know,
I'm in,
I'm in the bathroom,
um,
restaurant and I go to the bathroom,
you know,
by the way that I went to the bathroom,
you could definitely tell I had to shit.
I was,
I was moving fast.
you know,
it was one of those bro,
why you eating?
Yeah,
I'm eating bad so I didn't eat bad and while my stomach immediately said this is
not going to happen today.
So I get up and I go and literally like,
like three seconds.
I hear it as I'm walking over there go Kevin Hart and as I'm walking by,
a guy gets up,
follows me in the bathroom and he's like,
Yo,
I gotta get a picture man.
And I said,
let me,
let me go to the bathroom when I'm done,
I'll take a picture with you.
I go to the bathroom.
This is a true story.
Hannah,
her bible hand on the Bible.
I assume the guy is outside the bathroom cause I,
as I'm going,
I seen him and I say what?
I say,
I get done.
I go to the sink,
wash my hand.
He was just sitting behind a wall and he's like,
got his phone out and I'm like,
he probably did.
He just take me while I was shitting did put the phone over the thing.
Jesus like I'm about to be on.
Oh my God,
it's over.
This is it doesn't my nightmare.
Here we go.
They're about to put something up of me.
Shitting is the bottom of my feet.
It's whatever.
But he's just waited and in that moment was so,
it was so important that he was in the bathroom and as soon as I got a call and
let's take an asset,
let's go outside the bathroom,
let's take a picture that's a bathroom.
I said,
I'm not going well.
I'm a nice guy,
man.
I'm going to take the picture.
He's,
I just didn't want to lose you.
And I'm like,
there's not even a thought.
It's not even a thought about,
it's a bath.
Right.
So weird as us and pass the minister.
This is a,
this is a pretty fucking weird moment,
man.
This is weird.
And all when you were waiting for me to finish it and now know what you got on
your phone,
right?
You're too big for me to ask to go through your phone,
whatever you got you got.
But I had to go out and take the picture and I remember going back to the table
just like what's happening?
This has strange at this point,
what is happening.
Yeah.
That didn't exist before.
I think if you were famous before,
people just wanted to get an autograph or shake your hand.
What pat?
We're past.
The autograph stage was all the time you get an autograph.
It's been awhile.
I don't know how to write it.
I would think I would know what to put down.
It's been a minute man.
And I don't,
and I want to make this very clear,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know it,
you know,
I understand.
Like once again,
I want people to more importantly understand the fact that I welcome it.
I welcome the moment that I can talk in and converse with the fan.
But it should be that like,
it's normal to date.
The moments are better whenever real,
you know,
and after a real moment you,
you get a picture because you're like,
Yo,
he was actually a nice guy or I know I did it that you would be this calm and
cool.
You don't even get to see how genuine of a person I am because the first thing
you do,
you,
you stick the camera in the face,
and that's when people think that you're an asshole because they,
they,
they have the intrusive moment that then gets met with it.
Can you,
can you please,
I'm sorry.
You don't have to just take it in my face.
Damn.
You ain't gotta be like that.
Wait,
look for that.
Yeah.
Turn on you.
Because now you get your moment.
You look for the negative moment.
When does she start getting weird for you?
But how many years in?
Um,
I know it's been,
it's been pretty crazy.
It's been pretty crazy for like the last four to five,
the last four to five years and the last three,
you know,
if it's gotten insane because now you know,
you're,
you're on an international level so it was global and the following is,
is bigger.
Um,
and it's all ages,
which is,
which is really,
really good about.
Thank you know for Comedians it's a different thing because you feel like,
you know,
Comedians,
you're laughing where in your homes everything is met with warmth.
So when you see a comedian,
and especially if you're a fan of a comedian,
you're associating everything with funny and you're just looking for the funny
moment.
You're looking past the normal moment,
you know,
it's like you almost are frowned upon if you're normal,
if you're just chill.
Right,
right,
right.
Cause everybody wants to find a moment.
They thought you were going to be funny all the time.
I'm supposed to,
I was supposed to pop lock
right on site.
You know,
if it's two in the morning and you run into me and I say,
hey,
how you doing,
man?
That's not enough.
When you work out your shit.
Now I've seen you at the comedy store,
but only once.
Where,
where do you work out your shirt?
I like to go to random comedy clubs.
You know,
I think I'll go to New York first.
Uh,
New York has always been a home.
Um,
when it comes to building,
uh,
putting some structure within a set that you're trying to figure out.
Once I got a skeleton of what I want to do,
I'll just go to west palm.
I love that comedy club,
the Improv down there,
and I'll stay,
I'll stay for two weeks.
Oh real.
And just go and run through some jokes.
I'll go to Utah,
I'll go to Denver.
Who Do the wiseguys.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll go to comedy clubs.
Just random comedy clubs that you wouldn't expect to see me yet.
But I'll do a hell of a run.
And the goal is to get out of there with just a foundation.
It's not to have a complete set.
I just want to get a foundation.
So when I'm done getting a foundation,
then I'll do a little comedy club run.
I do a full comedy club,
Ryan,
where I just put two or three months in and it's coming to club comedy club
comedy club and I'm doing seven shows a weekend.
And people were shocked that I'm there and then I'm doing it.
But you know,
that's my,
that's my gym.
That's how I work.
And I ended up leaving that period of time with a complete set after the first
three or four months that I spent,
now I have to do a comedy club,
three to four months,
don't that run.
Then I'll take it to like a small theater.
I see what my laugh to feels like in a small theater and I'll do a little run in
small theaters.
And then when I finally feel like it's at a point where I'm getting the,
the laugh consistently and the punchlines are working and I flipped it back
frontwards,
forward every direction.
And my story is a real rollercoaster and it has an ending where I feel like we
get off the rollercoaster and we're happy and you don't feel like you were there
for an hour because then when I go test it out in El arena and if the arena,
if the last or sounds the way it's supposed to,
then I'll say,
okay,
I'm ready.
If it doesn't,
then I'll go back to small theaters and then I'll go to an arena again.
So not too bad of Rina sounds way it's supposed to do.
I say I'm going on tour,
so sometimes it takes me about a year,
a year and three months here,
four months.
You know,
people don't understand how hard it is to develop an hour of standup material.
people act like you just turn on a new hour.
It's,
it's an hour to get to an hour.
You're going through four to five hours of bullshit that you thought was funny.
Yeah.
To come up to that hour that you finally say,
this is going to be the representation of me this year.
Yeah.
It's a lot for me to do that.
Especially at this level,
you know?
Well especially while you're always doing movies and you're always busy with a
bunch of other stuff too.
Stuff that you don't have.
I mean you don't take any breaks.
Why tour?
I actually,
you know,
when I'm touring,
if there's a movie,
I made the movie schedule around the tour,
so my shooting days,
we'll go Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday wrapped Thursday,
maybe have a show Thursday night and then I'm going Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
sometimes no show Sunday,
sometimes show Sunday depending on what the work schedule and the workload for
the following week would look like.
So I'm implementing that in,
so when I say I'm out,
I'm out,
I'm gone.
So I knocked that movie out in two months and then when I'm not that tour
schedule shifts.
So the Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday,
dedicated to family,
dedicated to the office,
everything.
Then those weekends a tour,
but the tour lasts for a year and a half.
I mean this year we did 157 shows on my air responsible to her wow.
Hundred and 57 show before you decided to put it on the Netflix special?
Yeah,
we did the Netflix,
the taping.
I think I did it three weeks before we were done,
so we were probably at 143 shows.
Oh Wow.
Then I taped it and finished the tour.
Did you always have this kind of structure?
Like when did you,
how did you design this thought out individually?
You seem like I'm a,
I'm a well thought out individual.
Everything is,
it's not random.
No.
Everything is planned.
If you look at all my standup specials,
there's a two year gap in between them.
So the two year gap is because at the end of that second year,
my new special should be coming out when a new special should be coming out.
I'm now focusing on what the next special is going to be.
So that first year is all development.
Like right now I'm off,
I'm not touring,
but now I'm mentally in the gym and throwing all the old stuff that I talked
about a way that's now thrown out.
Can't repeat it,
can't say it.
Now it's talking about what the new version of myself is going to be.
What do I want the conversation to be?
What's my thanking and just taking notes.
So eventually now I'm going to start just popping up a random comedy clubs and
trying to figure out what the next thing is.
So by mid,
mid 20 I'd probably be doing comedy clubs.
By the end of 20,
I should have a full fledge concept that that new hour and by the beginning of
21 I should be ready to go out with my new hour.
End of 21 film.
I knew our mid 20 to the hour would come out.
That seems like a schedule a lot of people are doing now.
The two years schedule.
It's a perfect get.
That's how I do.
I,
I know Louis C K did a year every year.
George Carlin did every year,
but I think even he said that really wasn't the right way.
That's tough.
A year's tough.
Yeah.
I mean that's a,
that's a shouts out to those that can do it.
I think that's amazing.
Um,
I think just for everything that I have going on and all of the different things
that my hands are in within the brand,
the business,
I need to make sure that I'm giving a 100% to those things so they have the
highest opportunity to be successful.
If I'm trying to cheat it,
then it's going to show it's not going to come out to the best of my ability and
will then stand up.
You gotta you gotta fucking magnifying glass on you,
you know,
you're always being judged off of what you did at one point.
Just like a musician,
you're always judged off of the album that everybody thought was whatever.
So the biggest thing for an entertainer,
artists,
whatever your craft is,
his creation,
how you recreating yourself,
how you constantly showing that you're growing.
For me,
the only way to do that is to talk about my life and the things that grow along
with me.
The only thing that grows in long with me,
my experiences,
my family,
my marriage,
my mistakes,
my ups,
my downs.
Those are the things that I can talk about forever.
Because as you get older,
things change.
Shit gets different.
But it's all coming from my personal opinion of me,
my view on me and how I see life.
You can't lose material in this state.
That's why I stay away from certain things because those things can become
boring after awhile for me because I don't have the knowledge of everything that
I should like what,
what kind of thought?
Well,
politics,
I don't joke.
And the politics,
I don't,
I don't joke.
And anything that has to do with the slander of others or other communities,
I don't do anything divisive.
Good for you.
That's my,
that's my biggest thing.
And you know,
uh,
this past year was,
was one that got a little weird because I was like,
Yo,
I've really dedicated myself to bringing people together.
Like,
um,
I know that was my,
my goal.
That's my priority.
I damn sure.
Dot.
That's what I was doing on a global scale.
Everybody,
all races,
shapes,
sizes,
whoever you are,
whatever you are,
you can come to a Kevin Hart.
She don't have a good time.
So when it came off as if I was a person that was divisive,
that was tough.
You're talking about the Oscars,
the Oscars,
Shit.
Yeah.
Time where people were just looking to be upset about things.
100 [inaudible].
They're not looking to looking at you.
Kevin Hart has just a human being like,
what?
What?
Who is he overall super positive.
They're not even concentrating on that.
I mean,
think about how positive you are and yet they tried to concentrate on some jokes
that you did what,
nine years ago?
It was a,
it's a,
it's a wake up call of understanding the towns,
but then more importantly,
you know,
for me it was okay,
I went through it.
I made sure that the people of the Lgbtq community really understand it.
Hey guys,
I apologize before,
but I'm apologizing again.
I'm sorry I'm not that guy.
I don't want you to think I'm that guy.
Then it just became the constant conversation.
They never happy that it,
it just became the constant conversation and now it is because I'm not only,
sorry,
I don't condone anything that has to do with hate to anybody.
This is no longer a conversation.
So guys,
I'm going to stop talking about it because now I feel like I'm feeding into what
I'm not.
I,
I know I'm not the world in public should understand and know to them not
because over this time period I've shown that I'm not.
So the apology,
once again,
I'm sorry,
genuinely,
but then it just kept,
it just,
it never stopped.
And at that point I just made a decision and I'm like,
guys,
at this point,
I just am making a decision to not talk about it anymore.
That doesn't mean that I'm being disrespectful to anybody.
That doesn't mean,
and I'm shutting down anything.
It means that for me,
I'm going to stop talking about it because at this point,
I don't know what to do.
At this point.
I thought,
I thought the apology is what you wanted me to do.
I did it.
Uh,
may sure did you understand that I'm not a hateful person at Nocca.
Don't hate,
I did that as stepped down.
So I don't take attention off of that night.
And those people that are there to be celebrated.
I don't want to draw attention to myself and what's around me.
I stepped down.
Everything I did was for the better of good [inaudible] stubbing away guys,
because I don't want this to be a negative night or a negative thing,
and then it still became a conversation.
So I waited for it to die down.
I went on my radio show,
gave another public apology,
may shouldn't he understand it?
I'm sorry.
I hope these words didn't hurt anybody.
I once again apologize.
I don't cook.
Don't hate to anyone.
I hope that you guys can forgive me for those jokes of all.
So now I say if you don't understand and that you don't believe it,
I don't know what else to give.
I don't know what else to do.
It does nothing else you can do that's very wise of you.
Nothing.
It's very wisely to step away,
locked up because if you didn't,
they would probably pursue it forever.
I mean,
does it becomes a point of attention.
That's all it is.
They just decide that this is something that they're going to focus on.
What I had,
uh,
I had a good talk,
and I'm not talking about this a minute.
A friend of mine,
Lee Daniels,
you know,
manly Daniels,
uh,
Lee called me,
told me what to talk to him.
You know,
Lee Daniels is director,
a producer,
the show empires of his biggest shows.
Um,
you know,
so he calls me,
he's like,
Kevin won't talk to you.
And,
and us talking,
he's like,
look,
this is a time where you could speak up and talk about,
you know,
the community that's been affected by hatred and you know,
hateful crimes.
You can step up and be a voice and say that you don't condone or don't,
uh,
stand with any type of hate or whatever.
You can take that stage and do that.
And I said,
Lee,
I said,
that's,
I understand what you're saying.
I said,
well,
why didn't you expect me to know what's been happening with in this community in
regards to hate and crimes?
I said,
I,
I'm not aware.
I said,
some people can just not be aware.
I'm not in the know.
I have no idea what's going on.
I have no idea.
Yes.
Within net community.
I have no idea.
When you tell me this,
I'm now educated and I understand,
so it's easy to simply inform.
Right?
Information is key.
When people get information,
they processed the information.
When you can process the information,
you go,
oh,
wait a minute.
That makes sense.
Hey,
if you guys think that I can,
don't hate,
wait a minute,
I don't in anybody that does,
fuck you,
man,
that's bad.
You shouldn't.
I can say that,
but instead when this happened,
it was become an ally,
become a voice,
you know,
and that's,
that's where there was just a miscommunication.
That's where a back and forth Kinda was establish that.
I think people just started to take things and run with it and I'm just not,
I'm just not one to feed into what I feel isn't going to eventually evolve into
a positive thing in a real conversation.
Yes.
When I'm,
when I'm trying my best to,
it was becoming tablet bullshit.
Pretty much talk a real discussion,
clickbait,
clickbait.
If that's the problem.
There's so much clickbait out there because it's such an effective way to get
people to pay attention at things.
Cause as you said,
people focus on failure and negative and anger.
That's where we want to say controversy as well.
We want to see what to see the anger and,
and you know,
why do you think that is?
Because he's just the times.
It's,
it's,
that's what's cool.
Now is that what it is?
[inaudible] call is being negative.
You know how you always have some people is a great example.
How you have people who mean you can talk about a movie.
All right,
we can talk about titanic.
Wow.
And Titanic.
One of the biggest movies of all time.
Fucking great movie.
He'll yes,
it was great movie.
And why guy for no reason go.
I fucking hated it.
Why?
Yeah,
like titanic.
Fucking bullshit.
Why Manga the Noah?
Now tell me why.
Why did you hate it?
I ain't got time told you about that.
The cool thing is just being different.
I wanna I wanna be completely opposite.
Denali's and treasury has the people,
you know what?
Nah,
Nah.
That shit was ass.
Wow.
Why was it as you had people that just like to do that?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And and,
and what happens when one person does it?
Another person for no reason.
I'll go.
Yeah,
me too.
she was ass man.
Hey,
I ain't like it either.
Did you see it?
Which I was talking about.
You don't have to know what they're talking about,
but she just want to harp on the negative tray because that's what's cool.
It's not cool to be positive.
Isn't that cool?
To be happy?
I don't know if it's a cool thing.
I think it's usually people that are really frustrated with their lives.
100% what's the,
that's the factual side to it.
I did a joke before.
It was like,
do you think Michael Jordan leaves Youtube comments like,
I bet he does now.
That's awful winters.
No,
not at all.
People that want to get mad and complain constantly about shit like that.
Do you know what it takes to do this right here?
Right here?
I would tell you how I feel riding your comments section.
Joe Rogan,
you king,
Kiss My,
you know what that takes you or do you have going on that you have the time to
just simply be that negative and and do it in this world and uniforms.
Just a mismanagement of your time.
Time is so valuable and I don't think people understand how valuable they can be
if they use their time correctly.
Yeah.
Now,
have you always been like this?
You always been this outages fucking guy,
man,
but Hawaii's always really,
I find a light in every dark tunnel.
I will find a goddamn lightning.
I hear it all.
You'd listen when I tell you to wait on my back is so heavy of all the stuff
that I deal with and I'm fine.
The reason why I'm fine is because I'm genuinely happy.
I'm happy and I'm not happy.
Just because of the success.
The success acts as a bonus.
I'm happy because I truly know the definition and the feeling that comes with
happiness.
I truly know it.
I've felt it.
I felt it when I said,
Yo,
what really makes me happy and I'm looking at heaven and Hendrickson.
I look as though I look at my wife,
I go,
Yo,
I didn't have the family shit when I was coming up.
Y'All got one.
I got one.
Look,
what I done did,
look what I built.
These people depend on me.
I provide for these people.
That makes me happy.
When my daughter comes up,
dad,
you're not only my dad,
you're my best friend.
Yo,
I'm happy.
That's my world.
So everything else from the outside that comes in,
you're,
you're throwing shit at a,
at a,
at a bubble that can't be popped.
There's a force field around me.
There's a force field around me because what matters,
what really matters loves me wholeheartedly.
And when you had that and you understand that you're unbreakable,
so if you don't add to that force field,
if you don't make my force field stronger,
you don't,
you don't get time for me.
My team hartbeat productions,
the people underneath my umbrella.
You're part of my force field.
You believe what I believe.
We all see the same things.
We want the same things.
So we march with the same beat.
You can't,
you can't shake that.
We,
you're an individual that seen it and understands that if you've never felt that
we had no idea what that feels like,
then it's easy to shake you.
That's why some people are easily broken.
Being broken is not a hard thing.
It's not a hard thing.
So those that do get broken,
those that do get down,
those that do get depressed.
I understand,
I understand.
I don't,
I don't knock people for it.
I don't knock anybody for it.
What I also understand is that the encouragement that can come from so many can
add value for those that may need a little push,
that may need a little a Mepi Kitchener.
It's so easy to be that positive reinforcement for somebody and add value.
It's so easy,
but some people choose to throw that aside and kick.
Why your dad I to put out the light of positivity because whoever's out there
you,
I don't know what it could do for somebody else,
but somebody else may just simply look at it and say,
Yoda waiting.
He embraces his kids,
makes me want to be a better father.
You're where did this man doesn't stop in a way that every day he wakes up and
he's just positive.
Regardless of what's going on makes me realize that this shit ain't so bad.
The way that he gets up and says,
Hey,
today's another day.
It's a morning.
Let's all be better than we were yesterday.
Somebody probably needed to hear that.
The more that I can give that out and I can take my platform to throw good
energy out,
I'm doing my part because there's so many that throw out the complete opposite.
Yeah.
I don't want to be a part of that.
That's beautiful and that's true.
I believe you.
It's not,
it's not forced.
It's not phony.
It's not fake.
I guess.
Shit,
every day I hear shit every day.
It's very contagious too.
I had a lady,
I heard a lady right now,
lady rolled down the window.
She goes,
where are you going to make a good movie again?
I said,
did you see the upside?
I thought the upside was good.
What's that?
Oh Shit.
It's a movie.
It's one of my movies that's out us think.
I think it's a good movie.
I didn't see that.
Alright ma'am,
you have a beautiful day.
That's it.
With such conviction,
like literally I could have said a lot of shit.
Like she rolled her window down.
You could tell she still had the crank,
so I'm like,
I got to set a lot of shit.
I
goes,
a lot of things that I can say to you,
ma'am.
Where are you going to make a good movie?
It's snapping
that one out the upside and you see the upside.
What's that?
Oh,
it's a movie so it's out now.
Amazing it.
That's how she chose to come out here.
I see it.
I get it.
She chooses to come at you with a negative.
I get it every day.
We're going to be funny again.
Try My best,
try my best.
If it's not working for you,
hopefully I do better soon.
What do you,
what do you what?
What am I going to feed into that and it why?
Why?
For what?
It seems to have been working thus far.
Are you getting this positive attitude towards life from life experience?
Are you getting it from books?
Did someone teach you how to find this?
I'm getting it from the experiences and from the,
the real understanding of perfection doesn't exist.
Don't exist.
Joe Know,
well,
we're in a time right now where people expect perfection.
You expect perfection and I don't know where this came from.
I don't know what happened that this is the criteria for living.
My true understanding is,
all right,
you got one life and at one life,
the goal for us is to live it to the best of our ability from the beginning to
what said the n in the middle and the beginning.
Middle,
you're going to do things.
You're going to make mistakes.
You're going to fuck up.
You're supposed to learn and then move forward with the understanding of what
not to do and when you move forward,
life may get better.
It may not,
but somewhere along the lines is going to click and everything that I went
through back here was supposed to happen so that now that I'm here,
I'm able to go ahead with such a high level of knowledge and I can make other
people better.
I can make myself better.
I could do more from a family.
Something happens.
My Dad is the prime example.
Crazy drug addict and not a jail.
Life was very bad,
very fucking bad for my dead son,
got successful son,
then took money,
gave it to his day.
Here's your house,
here's your truck.
Here's your monthly.
At this age,
I want you to live your life.
You'd have made mistakes.
You can't rebuild and correct the things that you've done.
I'm your son.
I love you.
You can't go back in and Redo.
You can't try to keep going backwards and about me.
You got grandkids,
go be the best grandpop you can be for these grandkids.
That's your focus now.
Where's this energy devoted to being a grandpop for the grandkids?
Don't worry about me,
but something happened in your life.
Something happened that took you in the direction to reap the benefits of your
son's happiness and success.
My energy is now contagious enough and I hand it to you,
so now you're able to give that off to all these other people that you're
around.
Something happens and that's an every single life in every life I under stand
that there's a payoff for Baird eventually cause payoff.
It can't be bad,
but for so long,
if you got the strength and the understanding to realize that shit will change,
it will change.
It's impossible.
Just like poker.
I don't know if you play poker nut,
I don't.
You play poker.
You can run bad forever,
but it will eventually turn around.
Once you grasp the understanding of the game,
eventually it's want to turn around blackjack.
You Never gonna beat the casino,
but eventually you're going to have a good run.
If you catch a run,
you'll do good.
Get the fuck out of there.
You waited long enough with the happened hair,
come catch it.
Leave.
Anything in life will eventually tie.
Good.
No,
but this is coming just from your own personal experiences.
How many role models that my mother do this way.
Nancy Hart.
Did she speak to you like this?
About positivity and about
my mom reinforced knowledge.
My mom reinforced you don't start things and not finish them.
You don't quit.
There is nothing that comes out of quitting besides knowing that you didn't
finish.
We finish everything.
You start it,
finish it.
If you're going to do it,
do it to try and be the best,
not be better than other people.
Be the best for you.
If you're in school and you're going to class,
I'm not asking you to get straight A's.
I'm asking you to get the best grade that you can possibly get.
Give me a 100% all the time and I'm a happy mother when you half as me,
I'm on.
Yes
Mam.
I want to do this.
I want to.
I want to play baseball.
Well then you go and play Mama like that.
No more than why did you start the season?
Cause I thought I wanted to do it.
Then you gonna finish the season.
You don't quit.
There's other people that invest time and energy into you.
You don't just quit on people,
but I don't want to do it.
Finish the season.
Mama want to swim,
then you going to finish women.
It didn't matter what I did,
I was never allowed to quit.
So now in anything I do,
when I pick it up and say I'm gonna Start it,
I've got to finish it at all.
Don't work.
It all linked the best.
Hmm?
It all ain't knocked out the park.
But I walk away saying,
I finished it.
I did it.
I did it right now.
Been Boxing.
I saw us.
How you working out with Rico?
Verhoeven fucking um,
first of all,
very strong kicker.
Manage man.
Huge man.
Okay.
He's a fucking beast.
He's a good guy too,
man.
Good guy.
But I started the jeans.
I started it and I said,
why am I doing this?
I'm not gonna be a professional fighter.
I'm not trying to be average a fighter.
I'm done with getting to shape.
All right?
Then I'll start getting shaved and said,
oh,
so much that don't know about the sport.
I at least want to make sure that I'm paying homage to the people that do this
for living by really understanding and learning it.
You know what,
I'm gonna get a real trainer.
I'm gonna get some real people to show me everything.
So when it's all said and done and I look back after my training,
I can go,
I gave it 100% and look at how good I got.
Look at what I'm a product though.
I spar.
I go get it.
Yeah.
Just to feel it did.
So I can say I did it.
You know else bars.
Brian Cowen does this.
You serious
me?
That's me.
Come on.
That's me dude.
That's me is getting it to look at this
blue is teaching yet.
Uh,
his name is big.
He's in Atlanta.
That's me learning how to turtle shell within punches.
Uh,
but you know,
he's a former golden glove guy.
Really good.
So you were in a cup and everything.
What I was at the sparring session when I'm like real tired,
Damn Yada,
got touch.
I think got my ass whipped and every couple of times,
um,
I can go over the guy worried about that at all getting up.
Cause I'm not,
I don't go crazy.
We head gear and,
but I'm not in there with guys that are trying to hurt.
Yes.
And that in neo was touching you guys that have no concept of reality or
control.
Like they're,
they're just helping me understand,
here's why you have to keep your hand.
That is a problem with celebrities trying to spar.
I think if you try to like,
you know,
that's why you work started getting all that facial surgery.
I series James Tony,
she beat them,
which is not a smart move right here.
James.
Tony is a mean man.
It's just an eye you can't like I don't,
I don't go in that space.
And you ever seen James Tony Talk Shit?
Well he spars and there's some of the most entertaining thing you'll ever find
on youtube.
He's just,
he just won't shut the fuck up all the time.
Beating your ass.
Just talking shit.
That's her Fitch got bitch.
Oh this ain't shit.
That's her.
That's him.
He's one of the best defensive fighters ever.
So he's really difficult to hit.
He's got that Shell going and standing right in front of you and you can't hit.
It was most frustrating thing in the world.
Yeah.
I had a guy that's got any Mikey have barn with Mikey.
Mikey hit me with three punches.
I thought,
I thought Mikey literally had like six arms.
This is a true story.
I said,
I don't know what just happened but I thought I had my hands up and no matter
where I put them he just tapped me.
He lets me feel it but not to where I'm like getting knocked out.
But I understand now movement,
I understand pivots,
I understand shoulder protection and that's my goal.
My goal is just to understand cause I can't do anything halfway.
Kev,
you trying to fight somebody?
Nope.
I just want to say to that did it and I learned and I can move and I looked
apart cause I put time into it.
Well as you learn it too,
and as you watch it and you start get trimmed,
then you start to look at a guard like a Terrence Crawford or Aloma Chenko and
he'd go,
oh,
now I appreciate what you're doing.
Because before you'd see like,
Oh yeah,
he beat that guy up.
he knocked the guy out.
But then you see like how he ducks under the left and fires back with the right.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh Jesus.
This is precision.
It's insane.
The respect that I have,
people that do that or the day to day is through the roof.
[inaudible] people that fight in the most amazing shape and the universe.
Yeah.
You're in the most amazing shape ever to move,
get hit for three to five minutes around,
come back,
do it,
come back to it,
and he's fights.
Go on and on and on.
I take my hat off to you.
You get three rounds out of me.
I'm breathing.
I'm a,
but
I don't know where the air is coming from.
I'm searching for it.
It's a crazy way to make a living too much in your brain.
Like thank God I don't,
ah,
I didn't have to go down that route.
And you know,
to those that do,
just make sure you just put your body first.
Like you said,
it's a,
it's hurtful when you see the damage that it can cause.
Yeah.
We were talking about that earlier,
like seeing guys as they start to deteriorate and it's hard because nobody wants
to tell him that either.
Everybody wants to tell him they got one more good fight and I'm,
and let's,
uh,
maybe at the end of the year then we'll decide.
But right now we're going to train hard and stuff.
It's hard to,
because there's no option c.
Dot.
Once you've established yourself as a professional fighter and you don't have an
exit strategy,
you don't want to do,
you know,
now at least,
thankfully because of the Internet guys are getting podcasts and they started
doing commentary shows that talking about fighting and just the positive.
Yeah.
Would you just sit there and just found the positive,
the positive within the end and yet there is positive.
Oh for sure.
Just don't,
you just don't hear it.
Celebrate it as much.
Well,
the dinner,
it was very positive for me.
I mean this is this show we do on the Internet.
I mean all that.
Not just podcasts but youtube videos and also information.
I know more because of the Internet than I ever would have without it.
There's not a,
not a doubt in my mind,
a more educated,
more aware person,
I want to say the Internet.
Yeah.
You get the things that you're able to find and search and I mean like you said,
you're,
you're able to self educate at a,
at a very high level.
These are the goods.
Yeah.
But talking about the goods.
So when you talk about positive Kevin,
how are You Ben?
Yeah,
I always liked that.
It's,
this is the things that I look at that is so easy.
You're not just positive though.
You're like crazy ambitious.
That's the thing that gets me about you and the rock for sure.
It's like the ambitions off the charts.
Like I know your richest fuck.
Like when,
when do you think you got enough?
You don't have enough.
There's no doesn't know enough.
I don't have enough because it's not over.
It's not over.
You know when when you put a cap on it yet you're putting a punctuation to it
and the the,
the ambition comes from seeing what's out there that can be obtained.
You know,
when you see what's out there.
Like what can you mean physical things like what do you see?
What's out there when you see where people are really gaining wealth in
knowledge from,
okay.
The business relationships that you're able to acquire,
the people that you're able to partner with a creates certain things,
different revenue streams.
What I found is as a young black guy from North Philadelphia,
the biggest problem with the biggest problem with Finn,
our community is knowledge.
We don't know debt.
Debt is welcomed because it's celebrated.
That's all we know.
Hey Nah,
good that credit card on them.
Fuck that credit card up and it is what it is.
They've got to figure that out.
I ain't got it after that.
Yeah.
Well you know what?
I'm getting student loans.
They gave it to me.
Then after that shit,
it is what it is.
I'm figuring out and I put the capability,
your name,
you put it in my name,
we could switch it up.
Whatever they do it,
then let's just put it in somebody else name.
It's welcome.
The hustle is welcome.
The knowledge of banks and what you can do or can't do is it's fucking,
you don't even get it cause you go to check cashing places.
He's like go check cash places cause I don't want to go through that shift.
The banks,
I don't trust that.
Go right there to check has,
please let me get my,
let me get my now take $30 whatever.
Let me get it.
The knowledge isn't given so it's not to,
you obtain that knowledge and understanding that you go,
oh shit.
Oh this is why you put money up.
Oh this is,
this is how you increase vs decrease.
Oh this is how you earn on your money.
Oh Wow.
I can gain wealth by investing in what the stock world is,
what,
how many people partake in the stock world and is there a part that isn't
necessarily gambling?
Is there a low risk part?
These,
the snap,
the information is in there,
right?
So it's not too,
I got to a certain level and a certain group,
people where I got it and now that I got it,
I want to give it so now I'm going to give it,
I'm going to give it to the people that I know needed most.
And for me that younger generation of black people that don't understand.
The cool thing is in financial longevity,
not in the now,
it's not in the moment for jewelry,
not in the moment for the car it's in.
The longevity is in building.
So at the end of the day you can say,
look at what I have,
look at what I worked for,
look at what I have.
That's mine.
Monopoly is real,
but you have to have the financial understanding.
And I teamed up,
I got chased on and we've done some called financial fitness where it's just
about me educating people on money really how to manage money,
how to,
how to be smart with your money,
but it's coming from a person that fucked up money.
I didn't always understand it.
I owed in taxes before because I didn't understand that in the beginning I've
had bad credit.
Credit cards wouldn't take me because I maxed out whatever.
I've been there,
I've done it,
thank God I was able to fix it and get on the right path and now that I have the
knowledge I want to give it because we simply don't know.
So when you say the end game,
the end game is getting to a point where I've taken all the knowledge that I've
been able to get over these years and really applying it and providing family
wealth when it's all said and done.
The last name Hart is going to mean just more,
a lot more than just Kevin hearted comedy hartbeat productions.
Hartbeat digital.
You got heartbeat ventures,
your heartbeat real estate.
There's so many things that the last name Hart will be attached to you.
So real estate,
Kevin Hart and sell real estate,
buy real estate.
I don't Saturday talk about yourself.
Yes,
I don't sell it,
I buy it.
But the reason why is because the investment investment.
But as you get older,
you learn this,
you learn it.
And,
and you know,
it's such a thing where you talk about um,
black versus white.
You know,
a lot of people do that and,
and ifly.
So like there,
there is racism.
Racism exists.
I'm not unaware of that.
But there is a high volume of it that's,
that's nonexistent to people that have good people.
And when you can merge yourself with good people and follow the paths that you
seated,
these good,
successful people have taken,
you didn't become a part of a world and group that nobody expected you to be it.
So for me,
I now have the position to do that and take all of these relationships and all
this knowledge and take it back to the people that need the most.
I like to share.
I don't want it all by myself.
Now are you doing this and the financial stuff,
you're doing this in videos or you look releasing videos?
No,
we're starting,
we're going to start off.
We're going to start financial fitness.
Like I said with chase,
JP Morgan Chase,
um,
Jamie diamond,
very good guy,
uh,
to shine de as well.
They're there help leading in charge of just saying how can we get to the people
that we feel neat,
they financial information the most.
So I said,
put me out there like let's,
let's go directly to the consumer.
So from colleges,
uh,
from high schools,
um,
senior classes,
junior classes,
going out and talking to people before they go into the next stages of their
life,
about the things that you should know before you get to speak to them and just
share personal information.
Are you going to put this stuff online as well though?
Yeah.
You'll be able to track and find content from it.
But I'm authentic,
so I said the best way to really do it,
there's a put me in a position to be heard.
I want to be heard like,
like it's a different story.
What I explained to,
uh,
the,
the people of JP Morgan Chase just when we were talking about this and that's an
amazing board of people,
uh,
that,
that are just figuring this out and the best way to go and do it.
And I said,
you can't have,
uh,
the white guy that's never been to the hood or who's not from the hood or has no
idea how the economy works here and what the real troubles are.
You can't throw that man and the situation to talk to people because I'm not
listening to you from the gate because you don't relate.
I don't relate to you.
But there was somebody in a situation,
Ned's lived it,
that's been in it,
that's been fucked up in it,
made it out of it,
and is now coming back to help.
Right?
It's a different ball game.
And that's what I want to be.
And you know,
we have other voices outside of myself.
I'm very powerful voices that are going to do it as well.
But the purpose is to align ourselves to really make a change.
So you can either be the conversation about making change and you can be actual
a part of the action to do it.
I want to be a part of the action and and doing it.
You'll also be able to understand my drive.
You'll get,
I do so much.
You'll get why my hand is in so much because I have access to it in.
The question should be why not?
Yeah.
The question shouldn't be,
Yo,
why is he doing everything you should be?
Why aren't you?
Why aren't you trying to do everything?
Why not?
Well,
that's the thing about a girl or que te becomes contagious.
Like what you were saying about surrounding yourself with positive people and
people that are constantly ambitious and that that there's fuel to that.
You feel good about that.
That's what you're doing.
I can,
I can say seeing you here,
right?
We walked around.
You show me a facility.
Loved it.
Beautiful facility.
You talk to me about how your podcast has grown to where you are now.
The success behind it.
I don't leave here and go Jada's dope shit.
I go,
Hey,
I need to do more work on my radio station.
Laugh out loud radio.
I own it.
It's mine.
I got a show on air.
But you know what,
Joe fucking motivated me to do more.
I want to make sure that we understand really what's out here within his radio
world because I just saw my guy in his space and I saw happy he is.
What's the success that he has?
I don't want to be you or beat you.
I want to take this energy and apply it to myself.
That's the purpose of scene.
That's the purpose of being smart with your eyeballs.
You should be a sponge.
So I'm a sponge.
So I come here and I look at how you maneuver.
I look at your set up.
I not only bowed down to congratulate you,
I leave and I said,
Yo man,
aspired to as dope as hell.
Jack can't wait the two years you're going to call me.
You got to see my shit.
And you remember I said I was inspired.
But you're gonna see what I let it grow into.
That's the proper way to get encouraged.
And motivated as opposed to being a hater,
hater,
and and competitive.
I'm a beat you.
It's not a competition.
I'm not interested in that either.
I share the exact same feelings.
It's not a competition at all.
So if you don't have people like that that are inspiring around you,
you might not know how positive it is and how it 100% how powerful it is.
If you see someone that's on television or on social media and you see them,
it's hard to be inspired.
You don't know them.
But I can say,
look at your circle,
right?
And in your circle,
if the conversation is all about what we hate,
I can't stand that song.
You see that new fucking car came out.
Okay,
that's shit his ass.
I can't stand that fucking car,
Yo man.
I can't stand in this city a lot of fuck we even in the city,
well we eat.
I hate that place so easy.
If you,
people don't even listen to it.
It's how easy it can be.
The smallest shit in the world,
the smallest shit.
But if it's always hate,
can't stand his fucking hair falls.
While we got these headphones.
I hate these fucking a hardwood.
Why the buzz here?
Stan is horrible table.
Hey Harwood.
How could you get around with a tape?
I fucking hate this shit.
Fucking cheers.
You ain't got better chairs.
I hate this shit.
Easy,
right?
So easy.
It's so easy to talk about.
Yeah.
And so many people don't realize it in a group.
You do it.
You Ping Pong.
Hate off of one another.
Yeah.
Alas.
It's funny.
It can be funny.
Funny,
funny.
It's just between yourselves.
So Patrice was,
it was one of the best,
one of the best funny haters.
Okay.
You okay?
You,
you bring up a good point.
Comedic hate is a different kind of a different kind of,
hey,
yeah,
comedic hate.
Rest in peace.
One of the,
not one of the,
probably the best Patrice.
Patrice.
I remember when I would talk and if I was saying something that you would just
hear,
what would you tell him about he's what?
What are you talking about?
You like just the way you talk bugs,
what your voice thing about your voice just makes me want to punch you in the
face.
We talking about here.
What do you would go after you too.
It kinda made you feel good too.
Like if you're a commerce it,
especially if you're a comic like a,
I called opie and Anthony wants,
I was talking to them and Anthony Anthony always has a gun on him.
Yeah.
He carries a gun everywhere.
Like he has a concealed carry permit and shit.
And I said to him,
I said,
do you ever worry that maybe you're putting out this energy and you're
manifesting something like some sort of an attack on you?
Yeah.
Because you're constantly dwelling on it and you always have this gun and
Patrice goes,
Joe believe in magic,
jumbled Levy,
conjuring up the warehouse.
Hey man,
a positive.
Ready to just start laugh at sea.
He is mad.
He would go after
you mad.
It was like you just want to step back and watch.
I remember he got bill burst.
So marijuana.
Oh,
Bill used to get so fucking mad.
Beautiful thing about Bill Barbara.
We'd be snapping at bill.
Bill was got to get my bag.
It's just,
it's not funny if you went up to him,
none of his funny you build like where's the punchline in it?
There's no punchline.
He,
he is so fucking mad.
We,
the comedy cellar,
the days that we had their man,
Bill Barber,
Patrice O'Neal,
Keith Robinson,
Jim Norton,
Collin Quinn,
myself.
Um,
when I say we would sit at this table,
Woo,
said this table for four to five hours and it will be nothing but beautiful
trash bins to one another.
When I say they used to give me so much shit,
that's probably why it's so hard to bother me.
Now the trashcans that I took from the age 20 to 24 and my young comedic career
about how awful I was,
I had a joke.
I had a joke way at the beginning of my career because of the times.
Let me preface this.
This was way in the beginning of my career.
This was a joke that I had about,
uh,
about a little people,
midgets at the time.
And it's,
you know,
it was so bad.
It was,
I got robbed by a cross side,
Mitch.
And the joke was I didn't know he was robbing me cause I was with somebody else.
So he was looking at my friend,
but he was robbing me.
It was like a play on being was very,
very awful joke.
I remember telling this joke and a phonebook comes flying on the state,
put trees through a fucking phone book at me.
I'm talking,
this is the where the Boston comedy club,
people in the crowd,
tiny little place.
All you heard was,
and you sit back,
it hits the floor.
I said,
Yo,
what the fuck was that?
And Patrice said,
read it is better material in it than what you're saying.
Crowds does.
Laughing.
He's Ugh.
They all,
they used to trash me so bad.
So bad man.
Uh,
Geo,
legendary Patrice,
some news story.
I corporate trees jerking off in my house before
I moved to La.
I'm staying in the two bedroom apartment.
I just got there,
but she was coming out.
I said,
Yo,
what you need play status.
I got two bedrooms.
You can come there.
My ex wife at the time,
uh,
you know I come home,
it's like afternoon,
like Patrice.
I'm like,
Yo,
you home.
But trace portrays,
I go on the back,
open up the door.
I said his big ass computer,
all I see is this back hunched over.
It's like baby oil.
Right?
And I come in,
I'm like,
Yo,
what you doing?
And he's like,
Yo,
get out.
Get Out,
You can check it off at my house.
He's so sick.
He's so fucking sick that he didn't stop.
He was so concerned with finishing that he didn't even break stride.
He didn't turn around and not have me.
Nothing.
You get out,
get out.
You just saw his back hunch.
He came out like seven minutes later.
It was like my bad.
I ain't know you was coming home,
dude.
I fucking Patrice ma'am.
I love him to death.
Love him to death.
Yeah,
he had the most,
don't give a fuck.
Hundred most 100% good and bad though.
You know,
there was,
there was a good to it and there was also some bad to,
you know,
a lot of things that didn't have been for Patrice probably could have happened,
but I think the level of not give a fuck yeah.
Uh,
prevented some of those days where he was almost too authentic.
Yes.
Like his like did you ever see that?
What was it Charlie Sheen's rose who's roast was it that he did where he just
torching everybody else that was on the roast and then he got up there and after
the fuckers on,
on my level,
why am I here?
Be here.
What you guys who,
who the fuck is this?
Who is this bitch?
Oh my God.
Patrice has so many of those things.
Yeah.
So many things.
One of,
one of the best to do it.
Uh,
if you,
if you are listening,
you're not educated.
I'm Patrice on now.
I asked did you just watch a Elvin and the room
bachelors,
some of that,
some of the funniest shit ever.
Man.
And so insightful.
He was so wide,
very smart.
The way people thought and behaved would say shit.
Like one of the things that he's said that I,
I tell people all the time,
it's a,
it's a brilliant thing that he said it was,
um,
I forget what controversy it was,
but he was on television with some woman.
Yeah.
Was saying that you should never tell jokes about certain things,
you know,
and,
and they were,
they were getting mad at someone,
I think it was opie and Anthony about a joke.
And he said,
you got to understand that all jokes come from the same place,
the ones you like,
and the ones you don't like,
the ones they make you laugh.
And the ones that make you mad,
they all come from the same place.
Someone's just trying to be funny.
Yeah.
Like sometimes they just don't work.
Work.
I had a talk,
I had a talk with the,
the,
I forgot her name,
but it was when I was doing all the promo for upside and they kept trying to
break down,
you know,
where,
where the jokes come from.
You know,
Kevin,
these uh,
insensitive jokes that you told back then why,
what,
what makes you,
why would you even say those things and the hardest thing for me to explain,
I was like,
do you think people think of jokes and while thinking of them think that they're
not going to be funny?
Everything that you think of an a joke form,
you're thinking of it because you think you're going to get a laugh behind it.
Yeah.
The gamble is if I get the lab versus not get the lab and you don't get the
laugh.
The joke was not funny.
If I get a laugh than I guess I'm on to something.
There isn't a bunch of thought that goes into the funny moments that we think
may be great bits.
Yeah.
I wish that I had a more logical answer to put behind it.
I said,
but I don't,
especially at that time of my career,
I just thought it would be funny the same way that some people think sir jokes,
one of the offer,
it's a thought.
Comedians are constantly throwing shit out there.
Yeah.
Constantly rolling a dice and throwing shit out there had the shit you role and
good.
Right.
It's not going to be good.
The other half,
maybe all right,
may be kind of good,
but it's all with the intent of entertaining is not with the intent of being
malicious is not what the intent of sparking hatred is all trying to make you
laugh.
Yeah.
That's it.
Like it's,
it's literally that simple from a thought within a comedian's mind.
Yeah.
Nothing,
nothing else.
And they kept trying to look for this like hard definition of why.
And I was like,
I don't have it.
I don't have the reason why I thought it would be funny.
And it wasn't.
That's the downfall.
That's it.
And the thing is about this art form is that up until 10 15 years ago,
there was never any discussion like this.
It wasn't so much.
So when we developed and when we were coming up,
there was no,
it was just like,
and there was always guys that would push the envelope way too far.
I believe Jesus Christ,
you see as new bid,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
And you'd be laughing.
You tell it to each other and be like,
well,
yeah.
And it didn't matter what it was a joke about murder or rape or what are the,
some people just date choose those dark subjects.
It's like they're trying to make us laugh.
Yeah.
Comedians,
the comedian's comedian.
There's always going to be though what you just in about your own,
do you know Brian Holtzman a hundred percent Brandon Holtzman.
Is that God?
What am I enjoying?
My funniest dudes and,
and,
and there's no way,
like I say no,
some of the stuff that I,
and we say Susan Smith,
that lady who drowned her kids,
I know,
I know who you're talking about.
Yeah.
And I know the moment.
But I,
I'm not familiar with all,
all that involve Holtzman was on stage that week and he's like,
I heard those kids were bad.
Oh my God.
I heard they sat that close to the TV.
They never put away their blocks.
There was spilt the milk.
Those kids will not be missed.
Yeah.
And you were just like,
what in the fuck?
I was like nine 11,
when nine 11 happened,
they wouldn't let him onstage.
Wow.
Mitzi shore would not let him onstage for months after nine 11.
She's like,
no way.
Keep them off the stage.
I can't,
I mean do you have,
do you have the people that just are dead?
They go for that.
They go for it.
Cause they want to hear you how in the back of the room,
they know that like if it's,
you know,
comics are there in the back of the room,
they're going to laugh their fucking ass off at that shit.
And,
and you know,
it's weird because right now within the times,
um,
I'm the comedian that chooses to be sensitive to the times,
you know,
I've made the choice to say,
I understand.
I get why he shouldn't say certain things and why you should avoid this,
that or this.
I,
I understand and I am.
But then there's other comedians that go,
you know what,
I'm more stage.
I'm going to be me and I'm not going to do that because people are telling me
that this is what I,
I'm going to go harder.
And do that.
That's,
yeah,
that just exists.
It just exists.
But I think it's easier to just say,
I'm not a fan that comedy for me.
Right.
You know what?
I don't,
I don't like the taste of this particular comedian,
so I'm not going to support a watch that comedian.
I'm going to find another comedian.
There's more to my liking.
I'm going to go and just turn my head like I want us to get back to just
understanding that you just don't have to support it.
Yeah,
that's it.
Well,
there's a lot of fucking options.
It's very,
I mean there's so many today,
yet there's never been more,
never been more comics,
high level.
I think about how many people were doing Netflix specialists.
There's so many.
He's never been more,
it's so many stories,
so I don't understand why there's a push to destroy,
which you just don't have to support her.
Like I think it's just a bunch of people that have an ability to influence
things now that didn't have an ability before and it's like they see a window
when they want to throw a rock.
It's right there.
It makes sense and I think there's something that,
but I also think for us,
like Amit,
for me in particular,
I really like fucked up comedy.
It's one of my,
it's like I like Quintin Tarantino movies where people get shot and killed.
I don't want anybody to get shot and killed in real life.
Yeah.
But I like fucked up comedy.
Do you know Tim Dillon is?
Yes.
So do you pull up that fucking video?
Him Being Megan Mccain?
No,
I'll write it out.
He is a savage dude.
He goes so hard.
But I saw this video.
I was,
tears are rolling down my eyes.
I was crying and I was like,
okay,
this guy's needed.
We need this right now because during this political correct push,
you got this big giant gay dude.
It doesn't give a fuck.
Let me see is an animal.
I want to say,
watch this shit.
Father died.
I had a baby will be raised in captivity.
It'll be raised privately to be greatest politician that has ever [inaudible].
My name is Meghan Mccain and I'm on a new show.
Donald Trump,
that fucking riverboat casino captain is talking about my father again.
My father was tortured for a hundred years for this fucking country and he came
back and he started seven wars because he's a gentleman.
Fuck you Trump.
I'm gonna wear my father's skin mask and I'm going to primary Trump from the
right.
Come on the view,
bitch,
if you're that tough,
come on the view.
You want it all this time to get a costume drama,
club dance.
You want the shit?
You want to fuck touch Trump.
You want to suck cock,
but I won't fuck you because the only person I'll fuck.
I started his clothes off
before my father died.
I had a baby.
He's the animal folks.
You don't know.
He's wearing lipstick and a wig and he's smoking a cigarette and address and
he's all over 300 pounds.
He's such a fucking animal
fucking animal
to
fuck you.
Why?
He's only five daddy.
Oh my goodness.
That's pretty damn.
That's great.
It's out there.
They need that guidance.
We need him.
We need guys like that.
I mean the the where we're just talking about when we said it's like,
it's just,
it's very easy to just to just say,
you know what,
the snuff me,
it's fine with it is like
everybody,
everybody's humor is different.
I,
I laughed,
I laughed.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a viral video.
It is this old guy trying to hover board.
He's like,
fuck,
he's got to be like 69 70 and you know,
his grandkids are there.
And he's like,
let me,
let me try it.
Let me,
And this man gets on this hover board and tastes.
If you saw Mike Tyson following the hover board,
his fall was worst than Mike Tyson's.
I'll never seen somebody hit their head harder and my life.
And I didn't laugh out of wanting to see his old man hurt herself.
I laughed because it was stupid to try to get on his hoverboard and the first
place.
And when he got up,
he tells the kids,
was it moving?
I
played this video with everybody because that should make me laugh.
Some people will watch it and go,
oh no,
no.
Some people will watch it and go,
oh,
Oh and other than just died laughing because everybody's humor is different.
Everybody's fucking hammer is different.
My humor is different.
Falling makes me laugh.
I don't care who you are.
I don't give a shit who you are if you fall in front of me.
No shadow them holding their laughing cause no shot,
no shot.
You don't stand a chance.
If you fall and hurt and me,
there is no shadow that I'm not
bust your ass something.
Something has got to come out.
Falling is funny.
I still think it's hacky.
I still think farts are funny.
When my kids Fart,
I left.
I still until this day,
it's the funniest shit ever.
Me I it goes out of it.
You stick,
get out of it.
Stay gas.
My little son,
17 months when he fired,
I laugh.
Something,
something within just the ability to just be fucking silly and stupid.
It doesn't always have to have a meaning behind it.
Some shit.
It's just stupid.
My eight year old farts on cue,
she thinks it's hilarious.
She'll tell you,
listen,
I got to talk to you about something and she starts laughing.
She thinks it's hilarious.
She'll fall down on the couch.
Last thing in the world,
she can't stop laughing.
It's the best thing was when you're talking about as a kid,
that's all you got and should only bit as a kid you got nothing else but farts.
That's all you get.
That's all you got to.
Maybe we'll have.
You should enjoy it.
This shit.
I still think it's funny folly,
but falling is number one for me.
Falling is number one.
My wife fell down the steps.
She got so mad cause I didn't rush to help her.
I laugh.
She had a wine glass.
Wine was all over the walls.
Oh my God.
What are the worst falls I've ever seen in my damn life got up cause she was on
one step.
The of the shoe was all following is funny.
I like it.
I don't laugh at phone that much.
I just deal with too many injuries.
I've seen too many people get hurt.
It's not for you.
Especially old dudes falling down,
hitting their hand.
I'm like,
I'll start thinking about brain trauma and CTE longterm repercussions and that
the last name after,
after the lab I'm near,
I'm right there with you.
They get the less,
probably better.
I'm right there with you was the one that's going on today.
If this dude trying to come up the stairs on this other dude,
did you see that one?
The stumped him and send him flying.
I'm like,
all I could think of is we don't see it in the video with that guy's head has
got gotta be smithereens.
Oh my God.
Key.
He had hit his head.
He fell back.
You haven't seen one of the guy who slipped and fell down a bunch of steps at
the museum and he falls in the water.
Keeps going to the goals and what a brilliant,
brilliant.
You can't,
you can't beat that.
Here's this dude.
This dude's walking up the stairs and this dude's like,
get the fuck off my porch.
Stop.
Leave me alone.
And he keeps calling me.
He's like,
don't do it.
I'll go do it.
And he got smacked.
The way he fell back.
He was no hands behind them.
That's all head.
That's all head Presevo to Nazi.
See that kick coming from a guy that says it's sad,
but you also have to realize a guy that size is carrying all that weight,
not modeling of a donkey kicks.
Yes,
100% is caved in and I got stumped,
but to not see it once again.
I've always thought that about fat people that if you really,
really fat,
imagine how strong your fucking legs must be.
It's the strongest should ever.
Yeah.
If you really get some power behind that kit and also if you've lost the weight,
you'd have these incredible legs.
That's a,
that's always a a theory.
Just what's entered here,
but I always wonder if the needs are going to shrink.
Wait,
what?
Because you see someone from behind,
they're like 500 pounds,
like their knees or that wine.
I'm like,
okay,
is that the bone?
Is that fat around the bone?
Like has the bone grown really wide took because your body does.
Your bones do get denser if you do like heavyweight like this.
If you look at like power lifter dudes there because they're dense.
Well heart of it is not just their frame,
it's that they're constantly lifting heavy things so your body thickens up to
you as you go.
But you know when,
when you know people that are large and make the dedication to actually losing
the weight and they stay away from like the weights and stuff and just do cardio
is sheds off.
So fans but he can't like I know I know a couple of friends of mine and lost
like 130 140 pounds and like if now just fallen in love with fitness to the
point where it's unbelievable like how their body is transformed and taking a
liking to the new,
the new process that they now they get addicted instead of food.
They get addicted to be in health.
Exactly.
It's totally possible.
Totally possible.
I've had,
I don't know how many people come up to me and said they've lost a hundred
pounds plus because of listening to my show and having fitness experts on and
diet experts and just talking about staying the fuck away from sugars.
Say don't eat late at night.
Yes,
Don sweeting stop eating at a certain time and give yourself more than enough
time to digest cal.
Your calories.
Start exercising.
Well,
let me,
I think the thing with me that helps me so much as I'm not a food.
You're not,
I'm not a foodie man.
I'm just not.
I mean,
I was born guy to go eat with I.
I'm just making a turn.
That's it.
I'm literally just,
what does that,
what does it,
yeah,
that's fine.
Let me get that.
This big chicken,
some brown rice.
That's fine.
I'm good.
You don't worry about eating healthy,
clean,
healthy eater.
Because I'm not a Foodie,
so it's not like it doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
Like I don't have the will or want to eat the bad shit.
So if you're passing by in and out Burger,
no,
nothing.
No nothing.
Naw,
man,
I'm black Frat chicken fried chicken cook tonight.
Now you showed me a pump house.
Popeye's.
Roscoe's is good too,
but Popeye's really pops over Roscoe's.
Yes,
man.
Popeye's.
Popeye's is fucking,
I don't know what.
I don't know what's in that chicken bed mats.
Pretty damn good at spicy.
Dammit.
Do you like the spicy spicy?
Set my ass on fire,
but I'm still going to do it.
Yeah,
I'm still going to do it,
but I'm just not.
I can consistently eat the same thing and be fine.
How was pop?
I was the only one who figured out that red beans and rice is a great thing to
have on the size.
No one else has it.
It's the best thing ever.
You know what I mean?
Why does in Burger King or Mcdonald's Popeye's red beans and rice pop pods is so
good,
so good that when I was younger I was about 22 I was on a bike.
I got hit by a car.
Right.
Not too hard to where I was damaged,
but I have Popeye's in my hand.
Like the bag I was riding on my bike and holding it one hand,
but got hit.
Never let go of the bag.
Wow.
That's how good pop Oz's the bike,
everything else.
Boom.
I'm there.
Popeye's held on to it.
Nothing was damaged.
It still took her home,
finished at meal.
That's incredible.
That's how get Popeye's is.
100%.
So that's my cheat,
my cheat.
It's Popeye's all day.
Other than that,
I'm a consistent either.
I'm healthy guy.
So do you take vitamins or supplements or anything?
I used to take,
uh,
multivitamins,
which inspired me to start doing my own.
Like right now we got bicycle shorts.
I'm a,
I'm starting my own supplement line.
Vital Hustle is like the love of vitamin that will kind of put it out.
But let me tell you why though.
I'm going to tell you why I'm even getting into this space.
So when I look at physical fitness and I look at this world,
I noticed that you know,
you have,
uh,
you have uh,
a great
what in need to look like.
Everything around you that you see,
like everybody.
Like everybody that's a part of this world.
They look so fucking great and fit when a talking about these products and the
things that they can do.
And I said,
you know what,
what I'm able to do and what I've done in my past,
I'm always bringing people together of all,
like in whole like there is nobody's alienated.
You know,
when I did my runs with Nike and before I got signed my Nike,
it was about bringing a bunch of people that never ran before and getting you
guys to get up,
just come run with me,
just try it.
And you notice I got people out that never thought they would fucking do it.
And we doing five miles,
we don't tend miles,
whatever.
It's just a group run.
Something to say we did.
I said,
how can I create a product where I'm putting people in a position to understand
there's a hustle and all of us?
That's what my multivitamin is about is the energy is to recharge.
It's the ability to focus is to approach a day with all of the tools that you
basically need.
It's not just about the physical fitness aspect,
it's about the health.
So if I can actually motivate people to take the step in the right direction of
health with a line of supplements that are driven for the every day individual
that may not know or be aware,
but once to engage,
but you're not in it to look like all these different people,
you're in it to be the best version of yourself.
How can I do that?
Teamed up with a great group of people to create the best possible products that
I want to do.
And I said I want to be patient.
So it took me four years,
four years to create by the hustle and how many different products you go right
now,
just vitas.
Vita hustle was my only one right now.
So it's just a vitamin.
Just a multivitamin,
but it's an amazing multivitamin.
But is it a single pill or is it a packet?
But now it's a,
it's a jar.
I should've fucking bought one.
Good job.
Jar.
Jesus Christ.
Let's mix it.
And so it was stuff.
No,
it's a jar full.
It like a pill.
Yes.
Pills.
Okay.
Um,
I'm gonna tell you the dope stuff.
This that's in it.
Um,
cause I don't want to not say anything and have it to where it's wrong.
So I always show up on the screen,
man.
Look,
how good is he,
man?
Jesus Christ.
I get it,
man.
Hey,
you got to see it.
That's why you hear the same thing on my phone.
Blueberry fruit,
extra scroll,
Scroll back up there.
Boron,
Biotin,
bit of carrots,
right in my name.
It's all good shirt.
It's all good shit.
It's more than a multivitamin.
I'll put them in a good e.
What does that stuff Toko.
Trenell,
tocotrienols.
Tocotrienols,
vitamin E family.
You've heard of that gym.
Vitamin K,
look it up.
All right,
Gastrointestinal.
It's a good thing too.
Is that everything that's in it,
you know,
it's not only as a researchable,
but you'll see why.
Like my biggest,
like as a guy who's not as familiar with the space,
I said,
who are the people that are,
they do it at a high level that I can incorporate into helping me build this
product.
So I feel like you're never going to do it by yourself.
You shouldn't try to do by yourself and you don't cut corners.
You don't go the cheap route,
you don't,
you don't do it wrong.
So then you have to go back and do it again.
Right.
So I went and I looked at the people that were involved with creating the quote
unquote best market,
the best things on the market.
And I put that team together,
put up a team of like four to five.
I'm going to tell you four years I spent a lot of money developing this shit
because it wasn't right in the beginning.
Had to go back,
had to do it again.
It wasn't right.
It had to go back,
find out the other things that made of the things better of things.
Great had to go,
right,
go get it again,
go try it,
go do it again.
Not Right.
What else is out there?
What do we compare it to?
And so I felt that now when I launch,
there's going to be a place for my product in a market where people will
understand that it's exactly what I said it was.
There's no lying.
There is no,
you know,
false presentation behind a product.
Kevin Hart's Multivitamin as much more than a multivitamin,
but more importantly,
it's something for everybody and more importantly is to spark the hustle within
all of us.
And this is the first,
there will be more,
but it will be after I've mastered,
done this at the highest level,
then I moved to product number two,
then I moved the product number three.
Before you know it,
you want to see a fucking whole line that Kevin Hart to slowly developed and
that people can actually believe in because I'm a be a product of my own
product.
That's the best thing in the world.
When you're a product of your product has to work for me before I say it's going
to work for everybody else.
So you take this stuff,
he got damn right,
I take it.
How long were you taking that?
I spent all his fucking money on it.
That might have taken a bit.
Taking the,
the one that's launching now for about five to six months.
Nice.
I've been taking this one.
I'm very happy because I actually feel the difference and the differences just
in the energy that you have with them.
There's not an energy fucking pill,
but I do feel a difference in my,
in my ability to last throughout my day.
Like I'm,
I do a lot,
man.
I do a fucking lot.
So I told you I'm starting at that five,
five 30 and I'm not shutting down to let nine 10 so our video once where you
were taking a video of your,
your trainer passed out.
Yeah.
And you're like this lifestyle.
It was right around when he shuts down a very unattractive sleeper about away
shuts out to to balls.
Ronald ever lie,
one of the worst sleepers you'll ever see.
So you take him with you everywhere.
Yeah.
My train has with me everywhere.
Wow.
Everywhere.
So he trained every day.
Every day.
Wow.
Sunday's a light days.
Light Cardio maintenance will be,
call it.
Uh,
not doing the same thing all the time.
We switch it up.
Love switching to the love,
finding new things within fitness to make it fun.
You never want to get bored within it.
So your,
your whole purpose is just to keep your vitality up,
keep your energy up,
just to keep it.
It's,
if I don't do it,
then there's a leg at a need to train.
I need to do it because I am mentally so invested in it now that when I don't do
it,
I feel like I've cheated myself in a,
in a day or a week that I've taken off.
I feel like Yo,
man,
I'm not myself because when I am doing it,
I feel like I'm always,
I'm committed,
committed to constantly building in reshaping,
in molding.
I'm working on me.
So when I'm not working on me,
I don't feel like my day that's supposed to be about me is starting off with the
biggest bang.
Right.
This is my advantage to starting off like nobody else.
My Day starts off before fucking worms in birds get up.
I'm,
we're time to get up five,
five.
And that's when you start working out a gym.
Five 15,
five,
25,
15,
five 20,
no food.
I don't eat.
I don't eat before a workout.
Yeah.
And that I'm not eating before I work out.
Never had been now what I am now because I'm getting older,
I'm more conscious of my body.
So I'm big with sports massages.
I'm big with,
you know,
making sure that Ah,
I'm,
I'm not putting myself in a position to get injured and overworked.
Right.
So,
uh,
getting stretched,
you know,
trying to,
to do as much movement,
um,
that as I possibly can.
Like when I say I'm a little walking muscle,
I really am.
So my flexibility is limited.
So right now that's my biggest focus.
So I'm about to start yoga,
trying to do that.
Things that can just kind of keep me in a position to,
to not tie in notes.
I don't pull anything cause I do so much.
You're going to do hot yoga.
Yoga.
Yeah.
How y'all do that shit all the time.
Do you really love it?
Amazing
Dude.
Every week.
Yeah.
On it.
Then it's kept me from doing it as the smell at as possibly in Navajo.
That's the only thing that's kept me out of it.
I was like,
you gotta move past that.
Yeah,
but that's what I hear.
I get pretty bad.
That's how sometimes it can hurt the police.
I go,
it was nice.
You just got to make sure that the people take care of themselves well,
you know,
be around smelly people.
I'll be honest with you,
I'm worried about myself.
I don't know what I'm gonna get.
Especially if you get there early in the morning and you know eat,
you won't worry about farting.
Yeah.
But the people that eat breakfast,
you're letting off and everything.
I had explained that to killer Mike.
He was talking to me about farting in the yoga class.
Can't be eating.
No,
you can't be eating before that earlier you gone.
I like to go either 6:00 AM which is rare most of the time,
eight eight eight 30 depends on where,
which place I go to too.
But you love it though.
Yeah,
I love it.
It's great for your head too.
It's 90 minutes of suffering,
you know it's hard.
It's fucking 105 degrees,
140 degrees.
When you get out of there,
you feel like you did something.
Yeah.
And it just changes the way your body feels too in terms of your range of
motion,
your flexibility,
all those weird connecting knots and everything
just get opened up.
And so my question is when you,
when you're just starting now,
like,
like I will be,
is it extremely tough in the beginning because you just got to bring a lot of
ice water.
Just bring a big old fucking 64 ounce,
one of those uh,
thermal flasks of ice water.
Make sure you have enough water and drink enough water before it put me in a
bag.
Yeah,
I understand that.
I don't need to be where people could see me.
Just wa what did he got?
Like a section in the back.
Yeah,
but you turn left and you turn right.
Everyone's going to see you.
That's what I'm saying.
Can I be in a place where they don't see me in the beginning?
Like I don't want anybody to see your athletic man.
You're going to be fine.
You're going to be tight.
It's going to be difficult for you to pull off certain poses,
but you'll be fine.
I'm definitely gonna do it.
I'm done.
And then you realize it's a challenge.
I'm definitely 100% going to try.
You ever fuck would you do to no,
that's next.
Yeah.
That's next to hear that has an x.
Just just listen.
This is what Rico was laughing because I say,
Oh man,
the left on the taters,
I've never thrown a kick.
As I said,
whatever you shoved me right now.
It was my first time doing it.
I don't,
I don't kick,
I don't know how to kick.
So whatever you show me this is,
this'll be me processing it for the first time and that day we did it.
We worked on in that they have to do a couple good kicks,
a couple of good front kick and I said,
I said,
look,
after I'm done with boxing,
I said this will be my next task is to learn how to properly throw some kicks
and to move with my bottom half.
Now that I've worked on my top and that's my next hobby.
That's your next house.
But Jujitsu,
Jujitsu is like Tussen and chokes and talking about you want to do that too.
Just this stuff.
As you get older you have to find shit to do.
If you don't find shit to do,
you want to lose your mind.
You would get addicted to that.
I just want to tell her shit.
You would like it because there's so much to learn.
That's the thing about it.
It's,
it's a long,
long never ending,
never ending,
never ending journey of shit.
There's also,
there's so many different variations of each different individual move and
entries into new moves and defense.
And then the structure of it is,
it gets so crazy.
It's so,
it's super complicated.
And my son,
my son does,
uh,
my son is heavy and to boxing and karate,
I got him into those.
So he,
he does them both.
So the reason why I want to do,
I'd just like to keep up with him so we can,
you know,
do things together.
I have trainers come to the house and we'll work out together.
He loves it.
So I just don't want to get left behind too.
I can't do,
you know,
when he get 17,
18,
which you say,
Daddy,
hold on.
Oh boy,
I don't want that boy.
You better back up when he started getting that much confidence.
I just want to be able to keep up and maintain.
So that's why I like to do it with them.
What's good for a kid?
To have them in your head to defend yourself.
Confidence.
You need that for confidence.
It'll help you avoid things too.
Well,
I tell my kids,
you know your last name puts a target your back that you didn't ask
for.
And we don't go and create problems,
but you should always be prepared for problems if they were to occur.
And if they do,
I just want you guys to know how to defend yourself.
So the things that I have my kids doing,
just have the knowledge and understanding.
And the worst thing is just not knowing.
You know,
they're growing up complete different than I grew up where I grew up.
You had no choice but to know if you ain't know how to fight that shit ass
because you're going to get tested.
There's no way around it.
You're going to get tried.
You're going to get robbed.
You're going to get your book bag.
Take it.
So am I gonna try to take you sneaks like it's the reality.
It's not a false reality that's real.
So if you're not prepared for it,
if you don't have any type of heart,
you won't.
Last.
From where I grew up,
heart was everything.
And heart was sometimes saying,
I don't care if I get my ass whooped.
I'm not going to be a bitch.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna allow y'all to think that this can happen.
So I'm going to lose today,
but tomorrow I'm gonna come back and I'm gonna find you.
I'm gonna talk.
Whatever that moment was,
it was about establishing any level of respect that you could and I respect
eventually turned into friendship from all.
So my kids don't know what that world is like.
They're never going to have it.
So as a parent,
I just have to make sure that you have all the tools that I can possibly equip
you with because my parents didn't have the ability to provide me with that.
They weren't in a financial space to to take me here and had this extra
curricular activity or this extracurricular activity and learn this,
learn that didn't exist.
That is the big conundrum of successful clay bird.
When successful people have kids,
the what made them successful is dry.
I grew up poor too.
We were on welfare and food stamps and we'll do it when I was a little kid.
And that always stuck in my head.
This thought like we might not have enough food.
Like I remember thinking that when I was little,
like,
what if we don't have any food?
What if we run out of food?
My kids will never feel that.
They don't understand what that is.
And everybody that I've ever met that's interesting came from some crazy
struggle when they were young.
Yeah.
And that's the thing of you're,
you and I and most people that are doing well in life,
you're raising your kids in a completely different way than literally what
brought you to the dance.
And the first one is the hunger of not being one of those people that's left
behind is what makes you successful in the first place.
And it's scary.
It's scary because,
you know,
my wife,
my wife told me,
she was like,
you know,
I love that you're not hard on your kids,
but you always make sure there's a lesson within your conversation.
Like I don't yell,
I don't yell at my kids.
Nothing's going to register when I'm yelling,
so I'll try my best to talk to you.
Even when I met my angers,
I'm a talk to you so you can process this because you need to understand what's
the problem.
You need to understand what's wrong.
And what I had to really realize is they didn't ask to be born into this.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like it's not their fault that they're coming up completely different then how
we were raised.
Right.
And we can't have anger or frustration that's dedicated and thrown towards them
because they got it so much better than what we had.
How do we make sure we passed down to proper lessons so that they appreciate and
understand and not take for granted,
right.
They have.
For me,
it's tough because I got good kids because students,
they apply themselves to school.
They listen,
they don't do dumb shit.
Yeah.
They want to play video games and stay up like any other kid.
There's no signs of a bad or or or crazy.
And the fear and panic is that you got to know that bad and crazy exists,
right?
This fairy tale they were in isn't real,
and at some point when I'm not around,
when your mother's not around,
when your friends or other family on around,
you may get tested with the other side that's out here that you've never seen,
right?
So I got to prepare you for the shit that you don't know exists.
I got to take you to Philadelphia so you can see.
I tried to show my kids where I grew up thinking it's going to be like a,
Oh my goodness backfired.
That's so cool.
Can we live here?
Shut up.
Fuck you talking about everybody hit a car right now around,
we talk about this when we get back.
Very,
there's,
this does not go as opposed to,
oh my gosh,
so cool.
Dad is so different.
Oh my goodness.
Walked him around a neighborhood and it's like,
it's,
it's not a reality.
You didn't have grass kindness,
dad.
Oh,
that's great.
What'd you play?
Wow.
When you hear,
when you hear these things,
it's so different,
man.
These were your steps.
The steps are broken.
How did you even play?
Oh my God,
that,
so wait,
where?
Where did was yours?
We lived on the top floor.
Not the whole thing.
No,
it's,
this is three separate units.
So the top floor was me and grandmom's the middle.
That was somebody else that was a neighbor and downstairs,
somebody else,
three different people lived in is one thing together.
Y'All are strangers.
Like,
Hey,
shut up.
Get my own answers.
Everybody in the car get a car.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to say at this park.
Get right in the car.
But when you see that that's the reality that you get hit with of,
I gotta make sure that I'm talking.
I got to make sure that I'm constantly teaching.
If I'm not,
then I'm not doing my part.
I'm failing.
You know,
took them to the neighborhood and showed them how stores are in the
neighborhood.
It's what we got candy from.
Here's,
here's what we would get little sandwiches from y'all walk.
We don't have no stores like this.
We can't walk to stuff.
It's a completely different world.
Why?
See people standing on street corners,
what they do on their B,
they selling drugs.
That's tough right there.
Those are people that your dad still knows they'd been there forever.
That's what you don't want to do,
but they're forced with these decisions just because of what they have to do.
You just need to see this dad is take you here to see this drove them all
around,
all around North Philadelphia,
all around South Philadelphia made sure they could see it physically.
See,
we go out the country,
we go to these resorts and islands before we go there.
We won't drive around so you can see what exists before you get to this.
This is why we have to be good people.
This is why we treat everybody with respect.
This is why your dad likes to give.
Everybody doesn't have,
I'm constantly beaten my kids with that information because then you assume that
everybody does.
You come off like such an ass hole when you're around people that don't.
Yeah,
what you don't
awesome.
The advantage that they had grown up the way they are now.
It's such a rare thing and they don't understand it.
There's no way they could small percentage,
a very small percentage.
And that's something that I'd never want to let go of either.
So I was in the back of my head so high.
You're talking about how,
you know,
are we going to have enough food when you were coming up?
Chris rock's joke is so great that he said tell by how he keeps a bag packed at
the front door.
Cause he don't
believed that this shit is,
he is,
I truly believe that at any point somebody's going to go,
Gotcha.
You thought you lived here,
did this eight joy.
And I was like,
it's so real.
Because even though you have it,
you can't lose the sight of reality of where you once was.
Yeah.
Do you,
are you comfortable where you are now or do you still have those thoughts?
Like this is this real cause you're,
you're at the stratosphere of fame and success.
That's it.
It's rare amongst the rare,
you know,
it's uh,
like David Goggin said,
you are uncommon amongst uncommon men.
I will be a hundred percent honest and say I'm comfortable
with the understanding of hard work brings great rewards.
This is a reminder of the hard work and dedication that I put into everything
that I've done.
I'm not content because I know where I came from and I don't ever want to go
back.
That doesn't mean I don't want to go back to the city.
That doesn't mean I'm going to go back to the people that made that don't want
to go back to living like I once was.
I'm going to go back and I want to help.
I want to inspire them,
motivate.
I want to show people to,
there is a way out.
That is a way to do more,
to get more,
to obtain more.
But I personally don't want to lose all that I've been able to get.
So I need to make sure I do everything to keep it
so I can't be consent.
Hmm.
So there is an understanding,
but I refuse to click on the switch of hi.
So even if you like,
even if you have more money than you'll ever spend for the rest of your life,
that's not what it's about.
It's about the inspiring people and the influence and constantly giving back and
moving forward in a positive way.
And the only way you can do that as a stack,
it's the story,
man.
Yeah.
You know where,
where we're all writing a book.
What's your book look like?
What is your fucking book look like?
Like,
yeah,
your life is a book.
You got a bunch of chapters in your book,
but when they closed that book,
how good was the book?
How good was your book?
What was the ending to your book?
If the ending to my book can be so amazing because of all that was done,
not the money,
all that was accomplish the first to do the man that did this.
He calls the merger between this,
because of his commitment and growth to this,
the communities would then,
given this made education,
this change the way to schooling was blah,
blah,
gave books,
gave computers,
gave all of the things that can be associated with you and your existence become
a part of the chapters in your book.
So my drive is about my book.
I was in New York Times number one bestseller.
People will be done.
He did it right in another book.
Yeah.
What's it happened?
What happens if you are to Tom New York Times number one bestseller?
If you get the two,
what happens if you get the three hey man,
how to books become successful?
Who publishes them?
I want to start a publishing company.
Hartbeat publishing.
Why not?
That's the thing.
All I'm doing is sparking the awareness in others to go,
why not?
Why can't I create?
Why can't I start?
Why can't I be a business?
Why can't I be a CEO?
Why came I be a Tech Guru?
Why came I fucking create cooking products,
lotions.
Since there's so much that some people just don't understand,
they can do.
Let me be a spark to show how much,
how many different that you don't have to do.
Just one thing.
When it's all said and done,
my book is going to be full of all the shit that Kevin Hart date cause I never
was content with doing just one,
two or three.
Why not,
Kevin?
Why are you creating fucking health and wellness products?
Why not?
I'm big one,
health and wellness.
Why can't I?
Why can't I try to create something that I've filled is fucking great and jump
into a space that I'm already in.
I already give 100% of me in this space.
Why not?
Why can't I talk about financial wealth?
Why can I go back in,
educate those that don't know.
Why not?
You don't get Tom,
I make town,
which you certainly can.
It's just so unusual that someone dedicates that much energy and time to giving
back and getting involved with the kind of projects that you're talking about as
well as be super ambitious with your own career.
It makes me happy.
Yeah.
I could tell I'm,
I'm genuinely happy.
Discovery makes me happy.
Like when you find different things to be excited about,
it makes me happy and it's weird when it clicks in school.
They used to tell you all the time,
information is key.
Read these books is so much knowledge.
He man fuck that book.
Got Ton of read that book.
I want to go home,
got damn sonic the hedgehog that that want to play.
I'm at level three I ain't got time to read this book.
The information and stuff that was forced down your throat at a certain age,
you just,
you just may not be receiving it correctly,
but then it clicks.
You may gain information differently and what you do with that information is up
to you,
but people,
people have different roles.
They can go down.
The education wasn't my pick of choice,
it,
it didn't do it for me,
but the knowledge and the common sense that I have naturally allow me to gain
information,
apply it differently.
It allowed me to grow smart in so many different avenues to where I said,
oh my God,
I found my niche.
I found my talent and now there's other things that my talent can take me to.
I don't have the all the knowledge and awareness,
but I can align myself with people to do that can teach me because now guess
what?
Learning is cool.
Yeah.
That's what happens when you don't have to do it anymore.
Right.
It's its own.
Your kid,
they force you into this school,
don't want to learn,
but then when you get out and you realize like,
oh,
this actually benefits me.
This make me a better person.
It makes me wiser.
It's 100% the reality and it's weird how it happens,
but when you go,
oh my God,
learning and knowledge is power.
Fuck.
They used to tell me this when I was 10 yes,
10 11 years old.
I heard that shit all the time.
Now I finally get it.
Damn,
I'm about to be 40 he all his time to get the Goddamn code,
but I got it.
Yeah.
It hits you at a different time and when it does be excited about it,
man.
Excited.
I'm excited about with 50 years.
I'm just now getting the 40.
Do you read books?
I don't read a lot of books.
Do you listen to books on tape?
I have listened to books in our wireless to what?
Tony Robbins.
He's great.
Tony's uh,
uh,
like
I like his approach to giving information.
Um,
I like his attitude in general.
I like podcasts.
I like things that are real and that are presented in front of me.
I like information that I can go to the source and,
and touch and talk.
So for my,
if I'm reading a book,
it's a book that was recommended by such and such and the person that gave it to
me and after reading that book,
I learned more about the individual than I thought I already knew.
And now I gained more.
Michelle Obama's book.
Great Book,
great fucking book.
I met her,
talked to her.
I've been in the same rooms as seen her success.
What is her book gonna be about?
Mm.
Oh,
read a book.
Wow.
I get it.
I get why it's moving.
All the units that it's moving.
I get while women are reading his book and walking away feeling better,
feeling like they can't,
I get it.
Oh Wow.
Hmm.
Certain friends,
Dwayne Wade,
he wrote a book.
It's focused on being a father,
his road to becoming a better father.
What he went through with this kid's mother.
How you developed a relationship than a bond with his son's like nobody else.
Wow.
Didn't know that.
D that's dope.
I love how you put it on page.
There's certain things that you just want to know.
Uh,
certain books help.
I understand why people read books.
I get what the information does.
You know,
the book that I'm working on now is all about the mental approach that you have
with life and people not understanding that your biggest enemy is you.
My whole book is about you battling yourself.
People don't understand is you against you.
The only person that gets in your way is you.
Nobody else is.
You know,
when you write a book like this,
and especially about something like this,
this is the way you've managed to navigate through life are,
do you do write it out in essays?
Do you,
do you,
do you have like bullet points that you,
you,
you think about and then once you have those bullet points and you head and then
you ride on those out,
how do you do it?
I was showing you that on your phone.
It's all,
all voice notes and transcripts.
Okay.
So because of your time you don't have,
you don't have the,
the time to sit and actually write.
So you need somebody that you can talk to for hours,
hours,
hours on it.
Hey,
I need an hour block,
an hour for me.
I got some stuff we want to talk to you about.
Kev.
What was that all right.
Book title,
idea,
subtitle,
ideas.
My dedications,
my introductions.
Um,
within my introductions,
these all powerful paragraphs and things that I was just sad that a now
transcript,
I get to go back and read it.
Um,
let me see here.
There's no conversation at all.
Marie,
one of them.
Um,
no conversation or,
and that's what the Internet has allowed people to do.
Any of that does allow people to skip steps one through 30 is allow people to
jump straight to 100 fuck you got a job off.
Take them down.
You should be dead.
Oh God.
Fucking can't stand this.
Whatever.
The hate of the anger is when listen,
one,
listen.
Okay.
When I listen and I can change,
I'm not that guy.
We're doing these weird things now that people aren't taking the time to sit and
think through.
What I've understood is that what people are doing has nothing to do with me.
I should always be a step ahead because I'm thinking differently because I'm
thinking about myself.
Making myself better puts me in a position to make others better.
Be the example,
not the problem.
The best way to take away the problem is to alienate yourself from it.
These are just thoughts.
Ah,
it was fucking thoughts.
I can go through and just read it.
This is a sort of just have these philosophies you your life and you just just
speak.
It was,
it does speak Dan,
so now this is all transcript.
Look along with this.
That's incredible.
This is all fucking transcript.
This is all.
So I'll just go back throughout the day and I've read it and I say,
this is great.
This makes sense.
This didn't let me reword this.
I mean make sure that it's all flowing together and at the end of the day,
what's my reason for the book?
My reason for the book is to make people better.
My reason for the book is to make people understand.
Yeah,
we all agree.
We all should think that we're great.
There's no reason for you to not think that you're great.
If you don't think you're great,
ask yourself why?
Why don't you think the highest of yourself when you do people who have no,
you have no choice but to follow suit.
Hmm.
You got no choice but the pharmaceutic
a lot of people,
their base it on their past.
They base it on the life that they've experienced up until this moment makes you
better.
Yeah,
it does make a batch of bad.
Better makes you smarter.
Yeah.
Like you say it.
Yeah man.
That's what's interesting about it.
That's what's interesting about life.
You can hear a guy like you say that and then it changes your perspective and
then you'll go out and take action that you might not have taken before.
I had a five 85 on my sat confessions.
I didn't even take my confession and get you 400 for putting your name on a
paper.
It's true story.
Wow.
I guess a,
B,
a,
c,
a d.
A.
I did advocate Daba
true stories.
Swear to God.
My hand on my mother's grave,
a,
B,
a c,
a d eight all the way.
I didn't care
because it was a class trip that saved day.
I wanted to go.
Great adventure.
I was told that not taking my sats seriously,
but prohibit me from furthering myself in life.
That's what I was told at the moment.
I said,
damn,
maybe I should have.
Maybe I should apply myself.
Maybe I shouldn't did different.
When I saw all my friends get their test scores back and they were static,
800 909 sixties everybody's going to college.
Fellow at the biggest idiot in the fucking world.
The biggest idiot in the fucking world because the same people that I want to
rush to go to great adventure with.
They had taken an sat the week before.
They already got their work done.
They did everything they were supposed to do.
So that moment of fun was real fun for them.
I was the only dumb ass that didn't prioritize and take care of my shit.
So I'm the only one going to community college.
Everybody's else off the Villanova Temple University,
Drexel University.
God Damn,
I just got left behind.
Why didn't y'all tell me that y'all did it the week before?
How do I tell me that we was serious about the college shit?
Y'All ain't telling me y'all was trying to go to temple or Drexel.
All weight
is because my life isn't their life.
Then they're focused on themselves.
Wow.
That they're doing what they're supposed to do.
A Jack Ass.
Go sit by yourself and figure it out because this is where you should be less
than learn.
Any opportunity given should be taken serious from this point on because if not,
you can find yourself feeling just like this.
It's hard to get down on myself a fucking moment and learn from it.
Learn from it.
Now if I got to take a Goddamn test,
you best believe I'm studying for that fun test cause I don't want to feel like
I'm the guy that didn't prepare.
No,
I got a story to tell my kids about what it feels like to be the kid in class
that didn't prepare it.
It's got the worst grade when they give all those grades back.
But because of my experience,
I don't look down on those moments.
You take those moms,
you make the best of them because they'd live lessons.
It's that simple.
You're saying it's positive,
but it's really just simplicity.
That's real drill.
It's real and it's your life experience and it's your life's lessons 100% but
the fact that a guy like you comes out and talks about it like that,
that's where it makes it really powerful cause it's not just something that you
learned from,
but now other people can learn from your past too.
That's what I'm hoping.
They'll look at themselves and they,
they realize like we all start from a different spot.
You're not saying,
yeah,
this is why I'm so candid.
I'm so candid.
I'm so open.
They're there.
There is no like guys,
I'm,
I'm fine with being an open book.
I'm fine with the good,
the bad,
the ugly.
I'm fine being flawed.
I'm fine with all the things that have happened to me that have been exposed.
I'm fine with it all.
I don't hide from it.
I don't run from it.
I don't,
uh,
avoid any of it.
I'm fine.
It's all right.
It's a bed that I made for myself.
I happily lay in it and I'll be fine figuring it out.
Moving forward.
Sonos,
stop for nobody,
man.
Sundo fuck.
Stop.
Sign going to be up in the morning regardless.
As son is going to be up in the morning,
we,
regardless of how I fucking feel and how depressed I am,
the sun is going to fucking Shannon in the morning and a night time to move on
and be there and you want to look up these days going to keep going by.
So do you let the days go by and look up and you waste wasted a year doing what?
Or do you just pick it up?
All right.
Well and figured out,
made some mistakes that life goes on.
We figure out life from this point.
I'm a life goes on type of guy.
You're a bad motherfucker.
Kevin Hart.
Very,
very,
very inspirational and I'm,
I'm really glad you came down here and talked about it.
Um,
I'm more than glad.
I think
that it took too long actually.
And this is the first of a,
of what will be many men.
I'm for sure.
I'm a fan too.
I just think what you're doing is not just inspirational in terms of like what
you've been able to achieve and who you are,
but also inspirational and how you're so dedicated to helping other people.
That means a lot to me.
It,
it's very,
it's very motivating.
It's very powerful.
I want to,
I want all your listeners to know that is not,
um,
it's not the top.
No,
this is,
this is no way it could be you,
if you were doing that just for talk,
it'd be like listen,
just fake it and then become that guy because you know you're onto something.
If you could do that and just say it and dark web,
fucking forget about whatever it's fake or not.
You're on.
No,
I want you guys trust me.
You will be seeing more.
The financial fitness is real artist relationship with chase and now it's just
making sure you put me in a position to give the information that I have and to
the people that have really needed,
that's the priority.
Uh,
I will be sending more kids to college this year.
Um,
shout out to Tony Robins who's a matching my donation.
So you know,
I think I'm going to end up probably probably having about a good million to 1.5
where we take and we just dedicate that money and we just provide free
education.
You NCF helps me as well.
That's a priority.
Like I said,
this health and wellness side,
you'll see more from me.
Vidal.
so.com.
Um,
you know,
get a part of this hustle.
Go get yours.
Irresponsible on Netflix filming,
filming.
We were about to come out with that and Christmas.
There's so much,
so much shit going on,
man.
Well,
listen,
if there's ever anything you want promoted,
you want people to know about it.
I'm your man.
I like this conversation.
Thank you brother.
Thank you,
man.
Appreciate you.
Bye everybody.
Okay.